I've always been about helping people so
I had a problem personally right like I
I have an issue where could I got
divorced I couldn't eat a day for two
years and then I figured that out and
then very quickly other people started
coming to me for help but first I was
helping them for free and then I quit my
job I started doing this and that was
about seven years ago so I'm a full-time
romantic instructor for seven years
couple years ago we started thinking
like what if we started teaching
romantic rescue type stuff to women like
you know and how would that work out and
at first everybody on our and we were
very well we weren't sure it was gonna
work because the knapsack invention
between me and you like guy talking a
guy it's like well for girls pretty just
how many issues right no issues at all
actually if all she have to do is talk
to a dude and they'll be fine or I shall
have like thirty boyfriends if she wants
and that couldn't be further from the
actual truth like if you talk to most
beautiful women they don't meet one or
two cool guys every six months that's
when I first learned this I was like
really wow that's that's really rare so
I immediately went to sort of started
teaching them what I teaching that
except I reversed it right and very
quickly when we got results very very
fast the point where then so meeting one
or two guys over six months of meeting
one or two guys over two days so now
they have a choice now they can pick the
right guy whatever kind of relationships
they want and so it was sort of a you
know a transformational journey for us
because we didn't know that would be
that successful you see me fix specific
issues like a woman will have the next
episode for example is a woman that's
really tall and guys are always like
intimidated by her height right and so
we're doing all these things to address
that specific issue all right so should
start a conversation with like hey my
eyes
because okay you should be like don't
hate me because I'm sure which is
hilarious but she's like 6-3 you know
we're looking for girls that have when
women that have specific types of issues
you know because we kind of have a plan
what the episodes are about and then we
cast that but all the issues are
absolutely real like you know all the
interactions and all the meetups that
you see that's all real there's no
there's no acting at all top tip for a
guys to not be logical cuz most men like
when a woman starts talking to you but I
hate what do you do but okay I work at
new media rockstars right but a better
answer for you is it won't ask what you
do you've got do you know what the
internet is and then should I of course
I know what the and now I'm creating a
playful vibe right and then at the end
of that story you can end up with like
well I work for a for a website we do
all these cool news stories meet other
guys right so it just that little change
makes everything different so like one
of the things I do with guys if I teach
to you how to communicate for hours at
time and sound bites is everything's
really interesting you know how women
are really into texting right because
it's all sound bites and it's like
continues to capture the attention you
can actually do that with your furloughs
right you just go on for hours like that
without even change it without changing
who you are it's like you're just
changing the way you talk and all the
sudden you go from being like kind of
boring guy to being super cool dad for
women the biggest problem women have is
keeping guys interesting to them I
didn't me speak literally it's they want
to keep you interesting to them because
what usually happens when a woman talks
to their guys within five minutes she
decides she's bored and walks away it's
like a like everybody's about to Marie I
talk to my friends they're gonna get on
my phone so what I teach balloon is
something called go sleeping where I
teach them to prompt men secretly to act
in a way that's attractive to them like
they basically communicate to you
suddenly in a way that they want that
same communication reflected back and
what happens is they most guys still
fail that test like it me know on the on
the girls game like eighty percent of
the sets when they see her just like
dudes kind of messing up in the girls
like I'm bored I'm bored I'm bored
and then she just walks away but but 20%
of the time like the guy will suddenly
get it like a guy that has no game
doesn't really have an idea
maybe he's young maybe super logical
very little experience with all the
sudden eyes and her charm starts to come
out just because of what she was doing
but he thinks it was all his idea but
she secretly knows it was hers so that's
really cool